hey T what's going Ono what's up what's
up not a whole lot man I'm I am Muslim
but also I am Arabic and I think what he
was trying to tell you was when
Christians say God or they pray to God
the Creator the father who you would
consider the father they pray to Allah
he said he said Jesus is is not the name
of God he said Jesus is Allah as a CH no
he's trying to tell you that Allah is
not Allah is not the name of God that's
just the it's just a generic word for
God right I got you I got you that's
what that's why he said that's why he
said Jesus is his Allah when he reads
the Bible Jesus is Allah that's what he
said I mean technically but when they
pray they pray to Allah or when they
curse they curse in Allah's name you
feel me no they it's in Jesus's name no
no when they say for example excuse my
language damn you they don't say Jesus
they say Allah damn you they don't say
that bro trust me I'm tell you I'm Arab
yeah I mean you can look it up yourself
I'm not I'm not trying to he just told
me Pro yeah he just he just told me that
his Allah is is Jesus so I said that
Allah is not God and I'm I'm talking
about Islam anyway and you know since
you already debated plenty Muslims when
Muslims tell you or when they say that
Jesus is Muslim that doesn't necessarily
mean that he follows the prophet
Muhammad or his teachings you know what
I'm saying depends on depends on what
Muslim I ask some Muslim say yes he did
some Muslim say no he just followed he
just submitted to God so depends on with
Muslim I'm talking to well in Islam when
it refers to the other prophets the
previous prophets before mamam it
mentions that they're Muslims and they
all had different laws to abide by
because all all the prophets came to
specific peoples no they didn't they all
they all abided by the law of Moses the
Torah bro Moses had different rules to
follow then Noah then Abraham then all
those prophets okay so the prophet
before Moses didn't what about the what
about the prophets after Moses did they
follow Moses's law the law of Moses or
what do they have a law bro in general
all the prophets that were sent to
mankind were sent by God so more or less
their law is exactly the same okay but
certain certain times you know the
specific times those prophets came to
the specific people that they were sent
to they were dealing with different
issues I got you what's the what's the
evidence that Jesus what's the evidence
that Jesus believed in this Allah of the
Quran and that he submitted to that that
idea of God what's the evidence of that
bro whoever Jesus was praying to was God
can can we agree on that he was praying
to God yes and so if Jesus is not
praying to the god of Islam then the god
of Islam is not God could we agree to
that not necessarily
bro Jesus was praying to the God and uh
the God that he considered was the
creator the one you know the beginning
the end the only one that knows the time
of the hour then that's the same God
that the Muslims pray to got you so so
if I if I'm praying to let's say that
let's say I'm praying I'm I'm saying I
believe that I'm praying to the creator
of heavens and the Earth the one who
knows the hour the one who is the judge
on Judgment Day and creator of all
things but I ascribe that to a statute
in my closet am I am I praying to the
god of Islam I mean no you just be
confused if you think something out of
your closet created well see that's the
thing so so just because I ascribe these
attributes and these descriptions to to
my statute it doesn't mean my statute is
the god of Islam so so if Jesus is
praying to who he believes is the
creator of all things the one who knows
the hour and judge on Judgment Day and
all that kind of stuff but he does not
it does not match who the god of Islam
is then therefore he's not talking about
the god of Islam makes sense no your
argument doesn't make sense really all
the religions pray to the Unseen God the
one the Creator when those people are
talking about the Unseen and the Creator
they're talking about the same person
really so let me ask you this for
example people are tell people pray to
uh Brahman for example and Vishnu the
the these are unseen gods are they
praying to Allah no see what I'm saying
so your Allah specifically has a
specific identity just because people
are praying to
what just a second just because people
are believing in let's say a an unseen
deity does not mean that they're talking
about your unseen deity that you have in
Islam bro yeah yeah even the uh the
Hindus bro they believe in an unseen
Creator aside from all the Vishnu and
all the the other godman is that Allah
as long as they think that he's the
Creator the one and only yes so Brahman
who they believe in they believe also
manifested in these different
manifestations and came and appeared to
Mankind in in in different ways takes on
different shapes that's Allah no bro
just like the Christians we believe the
Christians you just said that that is
Allah bro I'm not saying what they
believe about Allah is correct but yes
as long as they say he's the one the
Creator and the one who you know who's
going to judge everybody on the day of
judgment then yes that's Allah so just
to be clear regardless what religion
from I got you I got you so just to be
clear and you're a Muslim by the way
right right okay so just to be clear you
as a Muslim have the same God as the
Hindus is that correct they they just
are a little off about him but you but
you guys have the same God is that
correct as it is the same God as
Christians that's exactly what I'm
saying you're saying yes okay so you
Christians and and Hindus all have the
same God Christians say Jesus is God
Hindus say Brahman is God and Muslims
you have the unnamed God Allah right so
and you guys all believe in the same God
exactly man mashah as long as he's the
Creator yeah I got you Islam is forever
changing with the times I tell you
forever changing with the times I
appreciate it I appreciate the New
Perspective I didn't I didn't know that
no worries and like I was saying bro any
any Prophet that was sent by God that
followed God's law and God's order in
Arabic that's the exact definition of
Muslim Gotta Give me one second explain
Muslim is not a religion it's act one
second my brother one second my brother
explain are you a Muslim I am a Muslim
alhamdulillah do you agree that you have
the same God as the Hindus and the
Christians I believe that we've had
124,000 prophets they might have been
known by different names so yeah so you
call him Yahweh
Elohim right so Ezra 51 if you read it
in Hebrew it says
best so if you bring up Ezra 51 it
literally said I just I just I just
simply asked if you have the same God as
the Hindus and the Christians is just is
that a yes I believe that all religions
at some point were could have been
correct
that so we believe that 124,000 prophets
were sent and at some point they
deviated so let me be clear because I
maybe my question isn't clear do you
believe at this point in time that you
and the Hindus have the same God no not
today not at this point no so ATL says
yes you say no so what am I supposed to
go where Islam is supposed to be clear
how many are there in the world so one
second God logic how many Hindus are
there in the world millions billions
right so there billions how can we say
that all of them right some of them
might not believe in a single Creator
they don't but some of them do actually
claim that they're a single Creator and
is that single Creator the is that
single Creator who they call Brahman who
manifests himself in different as
different deities and different forms is
that Allah well we don't know do we
because essentially Allah lot is lost in
language does does Allah take on
manifest himself and show up as Krishna
and all these other deities and teach
these type of of course not well you
saying of course
not that's not what he's saying imagine
the confusion man this is amazing no
there's no confusion bro look at this
look at Jehovah's Witnesses right
Jehovah no they don't have they got the
same God as you no you see how easy that
is right no they do not have the same
the same God as you no of the moment
yet they still claim to be Christians I
don't care I I couldn't care less I
couldn't care less what what a heretical
false Doctrine tries to claim if they
try to claim that they have the same God
as me the fact of the matter is they
don't you get what I'm saying like like
for for example for example is Issa is
Issa the brother of Satan Issa which Isa
Isa been Mar than you thank you ATL for
answering straightforwardly let me let's
let's see if this brother can answer is
Isa bam the brother of
Shayan no how could you possibly think
that right but the Mormons say that so
are they talking about the same Isa but
do you see the deviation is that the
same Isa no I don't bro we're saying it
is the same guy but you guys ascribe
different attri he just said it's not he
just said it's not you just said it is
so I'm just
conf bro I said he is I said he's not he
said he is but we're saying the exact
same thing bro you're trying to confuse
everybody yes and saying no do you not
see do you not see the mistake that he
just made there ATL so what he's
basically said right that they've
created a fallacy or a false god right
now this is what Muslims believe that
the Christians have done also they've
created a monist they went from a
monistic faith into a politic Faith by
creating by making Jesus into the Son of
God so making Jesus into the Son of God
brings in Poes correct so you did the
exact same thing that the Hindu do and
the and the rest of them do you
essentially created a partner or an
equal to God so Allah can't have a son
Subhan Allah there we go he doing the
same thing as the mechans did before
coming of Muhammad Al wasallam he can't
ever bro he says that he Beth not nor
was he begotten in the Quran that's not
telling me what he can or can't do it's
just telling me what he does does not
God is one God your God is one God he's
not a man that's literally from the Old
Testament one time listen to my question
can Allah have a son um Can Allah have a
son I can't answer for Allah but I don't
believe he can you don't believe he can
bro it's it's asking it's asking the
same thing like if you ask somebody can
God create another God really exactly
silly questions so so okay so just be
clear Allah having a son hold on Allah
having a son is similar and of the same
line of saying ah Allah can create
another God is that correct that that's
exactly what the Christians say I didn't
say that that's what the Christians say
I didn't ask you that's what the
Christians say and no that's not what
the Christians say so stop lying before
I turn up on you don't do that so
according so according to your religion
I'm sorry according to what you just
said you said that saying that Allah has
a son is similar to saying or asking can
Allah have a son is similar to asking
can Allah create another God is that
correct isn't the son you guys consider
pleas please answer the question differ
question at or you're going to just get
booted I'm move on to somebody else yes
yes that's what you're
saying that's exact I'm saying yes bro
all right got you so then Allah says
that he can he can create another God
then hey bro elic can I just ask you a
question I got to get off the air no I
want you to focus on what I just said
your Quran Allah says he could have a
son if he wanted to so based on that in
chapter 39:4 where does it say that
chapter 39 verse4 so Allah just said
hold on hold on just just one second
guys I'm going give it to you but I'm
going just show you guys how you guys
just said that Allah is illogical and
Allah said that he can create another
God so Allah says he can do it but
you're saying that that's stupid one
second Quran 394 394 right let's have a
look at
this so let's read the Ayah before it
and the one after it before die before
doesn't help you all right so hey logic
bro let me ask you a question real quick
while he's looking no no no this is for
you this is for you to focus on too if
you can't address this then maybe just
come back next time but you need to
focus on this cuz you said it you guys
both agreed that saying Allah has a son
Allah could have a son is similar to
saying Allah can have a can make another
God so Allah says he can do that that's
not what I said I said asking God can
have a son is the same as asking if the
same as what asking what asking can
Allah have a son exactly and and you
said that that's stupid
so Allah just said that he can have a
son he can create another God it's that
he did not say that he could have
something so listen to this really the
wording is very specific let me read
this out to you okay indeed we have sent
down the book to you or prophet in truth
so worship Allah alone chapter 39 verse4
sincere that's not 39 392 that's 392 I'm
giving you the context of 394 sure so
indeed we have sent down the book to you
or prophet in truth so worship Allah
alone being sincerely devoted to him
Subhan Allah perfect monism there then
it goes on to say indeed sincere
devotion is due only to Allah as for
those who take other Lords beside him
saying we worship them only so they may
bring us closer to Allah as in they take
intermediaries for one second right
surely Allah will judge between all
regarding what they differed about as in
the Muslim and the Christians so God
will judge my brother you're wasting my
time can you get to verse four Allah
certainly does not guide whoever
persists in lying and disbelief had it
been Allah's will to have Offspring had
it being Allah's will he could have
chosen whatever he will of his creation
he did
not exactly so if he wanted to could he
have had a son where did they say that
read it one last time yeah it said if he
wanted to he could have had a son oh it
doesn't say son it doesn't say son oh oh
my bad it doesn't say son Offspring if
he wanted to could he have had Offspring
son or daughter but had had it been
Allah's will to have Offspring he could
have chosen whatever whatever he will so
if all I wanted to could he have had
Offspring a son or a daughter right so
had it been Allah's will to have
Offspring he could have chosen whatever
he will is that yes that Allah could
have had a son or a daughter if he
wanted he is the one the Supreme so
again the same mon one time one time I'm
GNA give you another chance to answer
the question directly bro what's what
are you trying to prove I need I need an
answer I need him because you you are
honest but he's being dishonest right
now one time based on the verse could
Allah have a son or daughter if he chose
to how do you will yes thank you so at
first you said you don't believe that he
could but now you just read the verse
that where he just says that he could
let me tell you what the point is for
this I'm going to tell you the point the
point was is that you both said when I
asked you could Allah have a son if he
wanted to you guys said no like that's
like asking can Allah create another God
if he wanted to it's that illogical so
Allah having a son if he wanted to him
having this ability to have a son if he
wanted to is a logical concept it's as
illogical as him creating another God so
Allah just said he could do something
illogical he could have a son if he
wanted to that's illogical based on y''s
logic okay bro you know the way you
stretched all out let me let me get back
to the main point here he says worship
him and him alone right then even in
that verse it says had he willed he
could have done and then in the same
verse it says worship him alone again so
he could have a son if he wanted to huh
but he says worship Him alone so he said
don't go towards politis could he could
he do it by himself well could could he
have a son by himself yeah or would he
need help well I suppose he could do he
wouldn't take a married woman right that
was already betro to Joseph right so so
Allah could have a son by himself if he
wanted to like he wouldn't need a woman
well he could create Adam out of his own
hands and call him son is Adam son the
Angels his son is Adam son he could call
the Angels his son are the Angels his
sons well that's what he said in the Old
Testament right wait
so are you affirming that Adam and the
angels are sons of Allah well I don't
think they're his like sperm sons are
they his sons he call them son as in
like they don't have a father so
therefore he takes ownership of them as
in like a guardian not I'm be I'm going
be very clear with my question again is
Allah the father of Adam and the angels
not a biological father so is he so he's
a father in some sense to the angels and
to
um I think like a guardianship father
yes so like you have a stepfather a a
guardian father so just to be clear so
Allah in a sense is a father to the
angels and to Adam